- Training for sports gets you
in a mindset of being perfect,
of being exact, of being disciplined
that carries over exactly to space.
I was drafted to play out of college
to the Detroit Lions in 1986.
And then ended up playing
with the Dallas Cowboys
as a wide receiver on both teams.
And then I was injured.
And it wasn't until after I left the NFL
that I was interested in
becoming an astronaut.
When you're launching
from Kennedy Space Center
on millions of gallons of fuel,
you are on the most incredible
rocket ride to space.
And, when you get there,
that adrenaline is still
raging through your body
and you have to calm down a little bit.
So, my training as an athlete
helped me control that adrenaline rush.
It made me focus and stay disciplined.
The first time floating in space,
you're trying to navigate
what you're doing
and where you're going with your body.
But training as an athlete
has you understanding
a lot more about your body.
And you're controlling these
little micro-accelerations
with your body as you push off of things
to make sure that you
don't damage anything.
When I decided to become an astronaut,
I saw it was very similar
to being an NFL player
because there was teamwork involved.
The quarterback is like the commander.
So, the quarterback sets the tone,
says "We're running this play.
Leland, you do the down and out.
And then I'm gonna throw you the ball."
The commander on the mission says,
"Leland, it's time for you
to take over this role.
You know, we have a malfunction.
I need you to do this."
On the football field, you have to
cowboy it up to get the win.
The win in space is when you get
your primary objectives done,
like getting the Columbus Laboratory
installed on the space station.
And the real win is when you get home
and land and you're safe and sound.